for centuries one of the great fears
from racists was the specter of
interracial relationships racist in the
post-civil war era worked strenuously to
enshrine anti-miscegenation laws the
1921 constitution and laws of the KKK
for example called for adherence to
quote evolve the distinction between the
races the infamously racist birth of a
nation was based on the fear of rape of
white women by black men modern era KKK
Flyers complain about the ultimate
abomination miscegenation which decrees
the death of a race race mixing is
against God's law this sort of
disgusting propaganda has thank God
fallen out of common fashion except on
the Left today over at Jezebel
thus headline actually Rams is a direct
quote quote I'm tired of watching brown
men fall in love with white women on
screen this is pretty incredible stuff
why in the world would it be so terrible
for a person with one skin color to fall
in love with a person of a different
skin color in fact the left has been
generating trumped-up headlines about
supposed conservative objections to
Cheerios commercials and old navy
commercials and State Farm commercials
involving interracial relationships the
left can't come up with any legit
sources who actually object to these
commercials so instead they find random
Twitter followers and then build the
story out of them but Jezebel is a
relatively mainstream left outlet
they're a deviant Natasha Keaney writes
quote the big sick which the news show
has been roundly loud in the press
lately including here at Jezebel and not
without good reason it's a funny
heartwarming love story based on the
true life experiences of co-writers
married couple Kumail Nanjiani and
Nanjiani and Emily Gordon but as much as
I liked it and I did I also found myself
exhausted yet again by the on-screen
depiction of a brown man wanting to date
a white woman while brown women are
portrayed alternatively as caricatures
stereotypes inconsequential and/or the
butts of a joke so the story is actually
based on a true real-life relationship
but it's still annoying to this lady
that's because even using a white woman
as a romantic lead means quote in the
complex hierarchy of power and race in
America paying quote lip service to the
one notion that has shaped the history
of South Asian and American culture
alike whiteness as the ultimate desire
the highest goal in defining oneself as
an American so racism against white
women who have sex with brown men is
fine but racism against brown men who
have sex with white women is terrible as
tini says called representation like
this furthers white supremacy and does
not
gage with critiques of white allies ship
the only disagreement between Keaney and
the KKK isn't on the appropriateness of
interracial relationships but on whether
such relationships advance or inhibit
white supremacy this seems weird but
intersectionality is basically the flip
side of white supremacy interracial sex
is a no-no because it might imply that
separateness for non-white races is
taboo the only strange element here is
that many people on the Left fail to see
their own hypocrisy when they don't
stand up to racism emanating from their
own side of the aisle I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the venture Pierrot show oh
[Music]
right so Trump was in Europe Linda
Sarsour makes it an idiot of herself and
says some pretty awful things we'll get
to all of that in just a second plus I
will explain why I am learning this
magnificent hat but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Birch
gold so if you are concerned that
perhaps the stock market is inflated if
you are worried that the real estate
market might be inflated if you're
worried that the economy is overheated
or if you're just worried about the
possibility of a natural disaster
knocking the stock market office
moorings or adorn an international
incident which seems to the possibility
of what seems to be growing you need to
at least put some of your assets in gold
Birch gold helps you do that Birch gold
group
so go to birchgold.com slash Bend when
you go there you can get a free
comprehensive 16-page kit showing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
and how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA I own precious
metals you should own some precious
metals everybody should have a piece of
their portfolio and precious metals it
has never been worth nothing precious
metals who would always be worth
something very safe haven for assets in
volatile times economically and while
the economy seems to be doing well right
now we all know and we all remember 2007
2008 you can see how things collapse
really quickly and that's why it's
important to have at least some of your
best hedged with precious metals so go
over to Birch gold group calm se go
birchgold.com /femme that is
birchgold.com /ban make sure they use
the flash button you get that free
comprehensive kit and make sure you ask
all of your questions let them know that
we sent you with that slash Battenberg
school David a plus rating from Better
Business Bureau 5 star ratings from
countless clients a really terrific
company again everybody should have a
piece in the in the precious metals
market and vertical it helps that happen
birchgold.com
slash Ben okay so the last 48 hours have
been very very rough for left the entire
week
very Rufford west actually president
Trump was in Poland and you know I
should probably before he jump right
into the news I should explain why I'm
wearing this hat so yesterday I was in
Texas the last couple of days I was in
Texas Texas is just a wonderful state
it's a wonderful state we went to a
little town in the middle of nowhere we
were talking with some of the people
there and they were talking about how
they were basically just able to build
their houses without any state
permitting without any local permitting
they just go out and build a house like
that's America man I mean that's awesome
California you have to get a permit to
retile your bathroom I mean legitimately
yeah if they get a permit to retile your
bathroom in my house it's it is an
amazing state it's why everything looks
brand china new over in the state of
Texas and so in honor of the great state
of Texas I'm wearing this hat it does
look like we took a picture yesterday of
me standing next to a truck wearing this
hat it does look like I'm about to
release a really bad country album and I
do understand we'll talk a little bit
more about this later but I do
understand that me and a cowboy hat is a
little bit in Congress but I have a
piece of music that I hopefully that I
think will help fix all that okay so
back to the news so president Trump is
over in Poland and he gives what is a
very very good speech to speech in
Poland is I think the best speech of his
presidency I think was much better
actually than his speech in Saudi Arabia
I was not a big fan of his speech in
Saudi Arabia I thought it was weak tea I
thought it didn't really focus in on the
issues that needed to be talked about
but his speech in Poland I thought was
really quite good I thought the Trump
speech in Poland really called out the
clash of civilizations that is happening
he is not shying away from the fact that
Western civilization is in a Samuel
Huntington style battle with other
civilizations that are attempting to
rise in take its place
so Trump had this to say he said that we
are going to have to ask whether the
West has the will to survive
the defense of the West ultimately rests
not only on means but also on the will
of its people to prevail and be
successful and get what you have to have
the fundamental question of our time is
whether the West has the will to survive
do we have the confidence in our values
to defend them at any cost do we have
enough respect for our citizens to
protect our borders do we have the
desire and the courage to preserve our
civilization in the face of those who
would subvert and destroy it we can have
[Applause]
the largest economies and the most
lethal weapons anywhere on earth but if
we do not have strong families and
strong values then we will be weak and
we will not survive
everything when he says there is a
hundred percent true you know I think
the values that he talks about
preserving I would like to see him talk
about a little bit more explicate what
are those values that are worth
preserving and it's not just the value
of being able to do whatever you want
it's judeo-christian moral systems that
suggest not only that you have rights
but that you have responsibilities and
I'd like to hear him talk a little bit
more about what personal behavior looks
like in that context what political
behavior looks like in that context why
it is the government was instituted in
the first place like foundational
principles need to be retaught Trump
obviously can get eyeballs whenever he
wants and I think that that's a
wonderful quality and a president I
would like to see him use it for good I
think he did that in Poland and so I
thought that that was a really
first-rate speech naturally the the left
hated it Trump also went hard at Russia
in this me she actually talked about
Russia invading Ukraine he said that it
was that he opposed his Russian action
in Syria he's talked about instituting
missile defense in Poland which is
something that that Obama withdrew from
and and you know all of that the media
ignored because that cuts against their
narrative which is the trumpet in
Putin's pocket here he is speaking very
proudly to the poles about the fact that
they need missile defense about the fact
that Vladimir Putin on their borders is
not a good thing and he is anything
score eiated by the media nonetheless so
here is Trump talking about Russia a
little bit during that speech yesterday
we urge Russia to cease its
destabilizing activities in Ukraine and
elsewhere and its support for hostile
regimes including Syria and Iran and to
instead join the community of
responsible nations in our fight against
common enemies and a defense of
civilization itself okay so there is
he's trying to draw a useful line here
and I think that it is useful so it's
funny when it comes to Russia a lot of
people on the Left have a very different
story than when it comes to Saudi Arabia
for example so they'll say about Saudi
Arabia and members of these Roenick
world we need them as allies in the war
on terror so you have to make overtures
to them when it comes to Russia both say
you can never make an overture to Russia
because if you do you're just involving
them these positions are somewhat
inconsistent I think what Trump is doing
here is he's saying to Russia listen you
go any further than we're going to stop
you but why don't you join us now do I
think that's delusional too I think
is actually going to join us in our
battle on behalf of Western civilization
no unlike a lot of the people at sort of
the the alright I don't think that
Russia is part of the common cause for
Western civilization nor have they
really ever been I mean Russia has
always had its own interests at heart in
trying to convert them into modern-day
Germany or modern-day France or
modern-day Britain is just silly it's
not happening but what what Trump says
there is is just fine there's really not
a huge problem with it it's not any
different than anything that Bush said
or anything that Obama said the media
went nuts on all of this so as always
the media decided that this was racist
and sexist and Nazi okay so Vox has a
piece today called Trump speech in
Poland sounds like an alright manifesto
and here's what it said this morning in
Warsaw Poland President Donald Trump
issued a battle cry for family for
freedom for country and for God in the
speech that often resorted to rhetorical
concedes typically used by the European
and American alright wait what so family
is something I talk about a lot freedom
is something I talk about a lot country
is something I talk about a lot and God
it's something I talk about a lot I
think you all right our bunch of crap
bags okay so I was unaware at the
language of George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson and Abraham Lincoln and and
every great American thinker of the past
two centuries all of which focused on
family and freedom and country and God
I'm not sure what is that's not blood
and soil like the alt-right focuses on
blood and soil in fact the alt-right
basically says that freedom is not even
something that is necessary that freedom
can be quashed by a powerful central
government on behalf of the quote
unquote civilization right the already
is not small government group and they
all right a large segments of the
alright are not pro god I mean they did
a lot of y'all trite thinkers actually
think that God judeo-christian values
are weakening that the sort of Nietzsche
and thinkers and in many ways so it's a
very weird critique from the left it
they're trying to fit an ideological
square peg into the round hole of the of
the alright is it drafted by Stephen or
the architect of the travel ban Trump
speech used the type of dire last chance
warning often utilized by the far-right
on both sides of the Atlantic the
fundamental question of our time is
whether the West has the will to survive
JFK said very similar type stuff in the
1960s and when Trump says we have
confidence in our values to defend them
at any cost can we protect our borders
will we preserve our civilization we
why is that a far right thing it's not a
far right thing okay this has been
typical American rhetoric again for two
centuries and it is the central question
for any country is whether you have
values you are willing to preserve and
will you preserve those by internal
action in order to preserve freedom or
and will you preserve those by outward
facing action but the left is so
concerned with labeling Trump Anansi
that they are willing to take language
that is eminently non Nazi and then try
and pretend that it's not the so Peter
Bernard who is just an intellectual
sinkhole Peter Beinart is a Hamas
apologist he's respected on the left
because he's anti-israel in his Jewish
he has a he has a piece in the Atlantic
in which he says the racial and
religious paranoia of trumps warsaw
speech he says in his speech in Poland
on Thursday Donald Trump referred ten
times to the West and five times to our
civilization his white nationalist
supporters will understand exactly what
he means well
why is that white nationalism like our
civil I'm Jewish I'm part of our
civilization the West is a
judeo-christian one a judeo-christian
one the West is not just a location as
buying art notes but it is an ideology
and it's an ideology based on
judeo-christian values that undergird a
system of constitutional freedoms that's
what the West was right that's what
we're talking about here but by NART
redefines the West and redefines our
civilization to make them a racist
sexist I mean honestly you can't use the
word our civilization the phrase our
civilization or the West then I don't
know what you're talking about like is
Aragorn a racist in Lord of the Rings
when he says men of the West when it was
was Churchill when he talked about the
West the defense of the West was he was
he a racist sexist I mean what what is
this nonsense Bernard says the West is
not a geographic term Poland is further
east of Morocco
France is further east in Haiti well so
so what it's a culture I think everyone
acknowledges that no one says it's west
on a map the West is not an ideological
or economic term either the India is the
world's largest democracy Japan is among
its most economically advanced nations
no one considers them part of the West
well that's actually not super true
actually now I mean there's like the
Japan is is largely considered if not
technically a part of the West then then
an outgrowth of the West I mean Japan is
in the Far East but their government is
much closer to the west than it is
to what we would typically term you know
the quote unquote ease did what this is
the thing when we talk about the West
the polar opposite of the West in
geography is the East but the polar
opposite of the West in political terms
is not the West its Islamic
civilizations bla myth civilization
right as we're talking about the West is
a series of values because the West is
but by nerd says the West is a racial
and religious term to be considered
Western a country must be largely
Christian preferably Protestant or
Catholic and largely white where there's
ambiguity about a country's western it's
because there's ambiguity about our
attention between these two
characteristics that's nonsense Israel
is a Western country Israel is pretty
far east and entirely Jewish it's all
Jewish and Arab I mean what what and
what but again the left is so extreme
now they've really boxed themselves in
because they are so extreme but they
have to then they're so interested in
getting from but they actually have to
promote radical insane rhetoric in order
to in order to get where they want to go
they're defending such an untenable
position that they feel the necessity to
pretend that mainstream rhetoric is now
alright rhetoric on the part of Trump
now what's weird about this is if
there's plenty of stuff the Trump has
done that you can label all right
friendly I mean during the primaries
he's routinely retweeting and
associating with members of the alright
I mean his White House few strategist
said the Breitbart was an outlet for the
all right like you don't have to stretch
to get here but the West is so out there
so insane now they've lost their mind so
much they've lost their mourned that any
reference to the West is considered
fascist or alright goodness gracious I
mean Winston Churchill spends his life
opposing fascism and communism and he
talked about the West incessantly and I
guess that would make him according to
peanut Brian and Peter Beinart a racist
and a bigot the left is so far left now
that they are embracing I mean the
lessons are masked over the last 48
hours between their attacks on Trump for
using the terms the west and our
civilization and them going after mark
10 Martinez consultants Democratic
consultants who wrote a column saying
that the Democrats should move back to
the center if they wish to win elections
again which makes a lot of sense you
want to win all of the states the trunk
just took from you
then you're going to have to abandon the
intersectionality garbage that you've
been pushing for the last several years
mark Penn is getting just excoriated by
the entire Democratic Party here's Mark
Penn on Fox News getting destroyed by
another member of the left
look at what happened in the last two
years of the Obama administration and
what happened in in that primary I think
the the Sanders campaign and it strength
also I think pushed Hillary Clinton to
the left the the Democratic Party got
fundamentally repositioned much farther
to the left and out of touch with
working-class voters working-class
voters really want to see the values of
hard work family religion as a strong
part of a party that they could support
for economic progress and I and I think
they got left behind in the shift that
occurred at that time well you know I
have breaking news from markets not the
1990s you know the administration that
he served in locked up more black
african-american men than those enslaved
in 1850 so everyone doesn't have fond
memories of the fall out of the 90s
administration right now it's not about
the Democrats losing their identity the
party it's about the identity of the
messenger not the message I'm not
talking about going back to the past I'm
really saying it's time for us to to
look at new issues hey let's look at the
concentration of wealth and power in the
tech industry is that working out for
working people
let's looking at gig economy jobs do
they have the kind of the kind you can
be saying reasonable things about the
Bill Clinton era the Bill Clinton era
was the most successful era for
Democrats in the last 20 years more
successful than Obama Obama that a lot
of things done in his first two years
and then he destroyed the entire
Democratic Party wholesale across the
country Bill Clinton actually got a
bunch of things done that ended up
paving the way for a more successful
country because he was willing to move
to the center I mean for all of Bill
Clinton's myriad flaws is a human being
and as a and as a political thinker he
was at least willing to move to the
middle in order to in order to get some
good stuff done like welfare reform I
mean he actually after after his massive
tax increases he actually lowered the
capital gains tax but the Democrats are
so crazy they're so far to left they're
so ensconced with intersectionality and
Bernie Sanders socialism that they are
destroying their own party and I'm going
to get to Linda Sarsour in just a second
because Linda Sarsour speech that came
out yesterday is perfect proof of this
but before I do that I first want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at the US
ECA so you're at home you got you're
sitting around and you hear the front
door being pushed open you run to your
safe you grab
done and the intruder comes in and you
shoot him what happens next well you
usually think number one in order to get
to that point you have to have good gun
training you have to know how to use
your gun you have to know when to use
your gun you SCCA the u.s. concealed
carry Association helps you learn all of
that but after you pull the trigger
you're going to spend years in the court
system it doesn't matter if you hit the
guy if you miss the guy you're going to
spend years in the court system because
the court system is not built for self
defense the u.s. ECA makes sure that you
are covered for all of that they educate
you they train you they make sure that
you are legally and financially
protected for after you pull the trigger
and also they want to make sure that you
get more guns into the hands of
responsible Americans so even though it
is after July 4th I think this is this
deal is going to last a little while
longer
in honor of 4th of July they are doing
the great American giveaway they want my
listeners to be able to have five
chances to win 1776 dollars to the guns
and ammo of their choice so that deal is
still on go over to Great American
giveaway rights defend my family now.com
defend my family now calm for your free
shot at 1776 dollars worth of guns and
ammo defend my family now come again you
should register with them in any case
even if you don't win the money for the
guns in the ammo you should be able to
know them if they've classes and how to
and how to carry they have classes in
how to in they give you all sorts of
education materials and then they also
cover you for in god forbid the
situation you actually have to defend
yourself with a gun they cover you for
after that that's what USC CA is for
every gun owner should be a member if
you are a donor you should be a member I
am a member of USC CA you should go over
and you should check it out go over to
USC CA defend my family now.com defend
my family now comm check it out and I
believe that you can still register to
win at 1776 dollars for the guns and
ammo of your choice to defend my family
now.com okay so the greatest proof that
the left has completely lost its
moorings and it's just pandering to the
most radical constituency on every side
came out yesterday so yesterday Linda
Sarsour who is just in egregiously off
with him being Linda Sarsour is the
women's March organizer and the left
loves her Bernie Sanders tweeted out
that he loved her and he wanted her
support President Obama gave her an
agents of change award at the White
House so um give me a little bit of
background about Linda Sarsour before we
play the clip that's got everybody
buzzing right so she actually said on
Sunday she called for jihad against
Trump right
she use that word and we'll talk about
whether she meant that peacefully or non
peacefully but first I think we need to
set the stage for who in this hour sort
is because the web keeps saying well
don't take that quote out of context
okay well I don't want to take the quote
out of context so I'll play it in
context and explain it but I also don't
want to take Linda Sarsour out of
context okay she's not just some Rando
who used the word jihad to mean a
moderate Muslim struggle within
themselves for greater spirituality okay
she's not she's not doctor doctor doctor
Judy Jasser I mean you see she's not
she's not any of these people she is a
very very extreme person for example
here's what you tweet about ayaan Hirsi
Ali ayaan Hirsi Ali is a victim of
female genital mutilation at the hand of
Muslims
she is now an atheist and she speaks out
against radical Islamism and Linda's
hearts were tweeted out about her and
Brigitte Gabriel another another ex
Muslim Brigitte Gabriel equals ayaan
Hirsi Ali she's asking for an ass
whippin I wish I could take their
vaginas away they don't deserve to be
women this is Linda Sarsour the leader
of the women's March right she is she's
a feminist icon okay this is what she
tweeted about the honors higher reads
which was a which was a movie about
honor killings and how they are now
endemic in parts of the Muslim world she
didn't like that so she tweeted honor
Diaries is hashtag dishonor Diaries
because it's disingenuous when it's
funded by representatives and
organizations labeled hate groups so she
can't argue with any of the content
she's just going to label anybody who
funds a movie about honor killings a
hate group okay here's a tweet about
Sharia law Linda Sarsour is a big fan of
Sharia law here's what she had to say
about Sharia law and I'm not talking
about Sharia law like the internal
governance of the Muslim community when
you have a financial dispute and you and
your fellow Muslims go to like in
Islamic court we have that in Judaism -
it's called Beit din it's not that big a
deal right in ecclesiastical court but
that's not what she's talking about
she's talking about the governance of a
country by Islamic law including areas
including criminal law she says you'll
know when you're living under Sharia law
it's suddenly all your loans and credit
cards become interest-free sounds nice
doesn't it well I mean number one it
doesn't sound very nice because you
can't buy anything in countries that
have only interest-free loans and credit
cards because who in the right mind
would provide such things right interest
actually happens to be I'm writing
something about this now biblical takes
on interest the interest happens to be a
rather crucial part of the financial
market but she's treated worse things
about Sharia law she's tweeted
with regard to women's driving in Saudi
Arabia for example she was asked about
well if Sharia law is so great why can't
women drive in Saudi Arabia and here's
what she tweeted and she tweeted she
tweeted 10 weeks of paid maternity leave
in Saudi Arabia yes paid and you're
worrying about women driving puts us to
shame and in just ridiculous just
ridiculous right mean she's defending
hey sad you're a because they paid
maternity leave well maybe that's
because women in town eurabia aren't
working very often okay and not allowing
them to drive is still a rather large
problem okay this is how Euripides not
famous for its woman's right she also
happens to be a close associate of many
groups that are associated with
terrorism the speech the chance she gave
which he of the Islamic Society of North
America which has been linked to terror
finding groups for years and years and
years and years and when it comes to
terror incidents she has a long and
unpleasant history of saying ridiculous
things about terror incidents up for
example here's what she said about the
underwear bomber you remember the the
guy who tried to put a bomb in his
underwear and then bomb a plane coming
into Detroit on Christmas Day during the
Bush administration she said underwear
bomber was CIA all along why did I
already know that shame on us
scaring the American people okay the
underwear bomber was not CIA gang he was
a radical Muslim who's attempting to
bomb an American place so this is who
Linda Sarsour is she's also posed next
to people who are convicted of crimes in
association with Hamas and photographs
she has bragged about having relatives
in jail in Israel
she has tweeted out I believe photos of
people getting ready to stone Israeli
soldiers she's a really egregious figure
and the left has embraced her now what
they embrace now what they've done now
is they've actually embraced her talking
about jihad against the Trump
administration's we're going to talk
about that I'm going to put into its
complete context but for that you're
going to have to go over to Daley
wired.com and subscribe $8 a month get
two subscription to daily wire comm dad
deal by the way expires July 10 so you
have like three days left to get in
under the wire there it's hard to July
7th July 10th the rates go up so if you
want $8 a month you get that
subscription you can be part of the
mailbag to the rest of the show live we
are doing live mailbag a little bit
later in the show so we'll be doing that
we do that every Friday
now you also get clava in the show live
and it is become an annual subscriber
and you get a free signed copy of the
book
with my dad say it's all about baseball
and parents and fathers and sons a
really fun interesting lovely read it
was really fun to write I think you'll
enjoy it as well and I'll sign it for
you when you get an annual subscription
you also get the entire daily wire
website ad free which is super cool but
you have to go over to daily wire and
subscribe if you want to listen later
just go over to iTunes or SoundCloud hit
subscribe leave us a review whatever
numbers of stars we're going to give us
just add five and that's your actual
proper rating and leave that overnight
oons we always appreciate it we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]